Buenos días, aquí Steve Kaufmann y
hoy voy a hablar sobre la importancia
de la escucha en el aprendizaje de
idiomas, si te gusta mis videos,
inscríbete, haz clic en la campana para
tener noticias y si me sigues en el
podcast, en podcast,
puedes dejar un comentario, dirá mucho.
Bueno, la escucha, la escucha, es la
actividad en mi caso en el aprendizaje de
idiomas, es la cosa que hago
lo más frecuentemente, ¿porqué?
es la actividad más fácil, es muy fácil.
Yo me levanto a la mañana,
puedo escuchar, preparando el
desayuno, puedo escuchar, en el coche,
puedo escuchar y durante el día hay
tantas ocasiones, aquí 10 minutos,
30 minutos que puedo escuchar y escuchando,
inevitablemente hay cosas que yo no
he comprendido, entendido,
pues este es una estimulación,
ahora quiero leer, para saber y
entender mejor las secciones de la cosa
que he entendido, que no he entendido, la
cosa que he escuchado que no he entendido
y no comprendo, Entonces es una, me empuja,
me empuja a leer y escuchando y leyendo
voy a aprender, porque como digo siempre,
el input el cosa, esta cosa de escuchar,
hacer que el idioma entra, entra en su
en su cabeza, en su cerebro es la mejor
manera para aprender. No se aprende
hablando, hablando es cuando se puede
activizar todas las cosas que ya has,
has aprendido y la escucha tiene la gran
ventaja que se puede
hacer cuando quieres.
Y es importante darse cuenta que no necesitas
enfocarse siempre no hay gente que
creen que deben, deben escuchar
atentivamente para no faltar cosas… no.
Yo escucho y de vez en cuando mi mente
está un poco distraído, no voy a enfocarme.
Voy pensar otras cosas para entonces
volver a escuchar y si yo escucho
como yo no sé 20 minutos si el período
de concentración es de 50% o 60%
ya es mucho, ya es mucho. Es que el
idioma está entrando en tu cabeza
aún el tiempo que no estás concentrándose,
y todavía está entrando en tu cabeza
los períodos que estás escuchando
con concentración, tanto mejor.
Yo tengo una estrategia que durante el
primer periodo del aprendizaje de un idioma
cualquiera, pues voy a escuchar muchas veces
la misma cosa, muchas veces sobre todo
las mini historias donde hay mucha
repetición de vocabulario escuchando
una otra vez tendría tanta repetición que el,
los neurones van conectar en mi cerebro,
este es durante el según el idioma, los
primeros 3 meses, 6 meses voy a escuchar
la misma cosa una otra vez, esto no quiere
decir en un en un rato, enseguida, no,
escucha la primera historia, la segunda,
la tercera, la cuarta, y después la primera,
la segunda, la… y finalmente al cabo de
todo, yo, porque tenemos las estadísticas
voy a ver que finalmente he escuchado,
una historia 30 veces, 30 veces,
bueno, no es todo el mundo que tiene
la paciencia de hacerlo, pero puedo
asegurarles de que hacer esto en el
fase, no al inicio, ayuda mucho
para que el cerebro se acostumbre
al nuevo idioma, tiene que forzar
en el cerebro crear un centro de control,
no por el nuevo idioma pero después de
este rato, pues voy a escuchar menos
frecuente, frecuentemente la misma
el mismo contenido porque ahora, bueno…
aburrido escuchar siempre la misma cosa,
entonces el cerebro,
que necesita repetición para aprender,
pero también necesita novedad,
necesita cosas interesantes
y después de los primeros 3, 4 meses voy
a buscar cosas interesantes para escuchar,
porque el camino es muy largo,
necesita mucho tiempo para aprender.
Entonces tienes que buscar contenidos
interesantes divirtiendo de manera que el
aprendizaje no es para aprender la,
el idioma para aprender sobre cosas que son
interesantes para ti, entonces la
estrategia de escucha, se cambia, se cambia
de una estrategia de repetición, mucha
repetición hacia una estrategia de descubrir,
descubrir no solo el idioma, pero la cultura,
el país y todo lo que tiene relaciones
con el idioma que estás estudiando. Entonces
y la escucha te prepara para hablar,
porque si tú quieres tener una conversación
con alguien en el idioma que estás
aprendiendo sobre todo un nativo, el
nativo tiene mucho, mucho más vocabulario
que ti. Entonces tienes que tener un gran
vocabulario pasivo, tienes que entender,
entonces la comprensión es muy
importante Si tú no tienes este nivel
de comprensión es muy difícil tener una
conversación de adulto con alguien entonces,
aunque la meta, este poder hablar bien
con cualquier persona la manera de
llegar a este, este capacidad es a
través de la escucha, la comprensión
la comprensión oral, si tienes este comprensión
oral, puedes mantener conversaciones
inteligentes todo el nivel en el idioma
va a mejorarse, entonces, finalmente,
la escucha es el actividad, más fácil,
pero la actividad clave para alcanzar,
un nivel de fluidez
en cualquier idioma.
Bueno, Hasta luego, Muchas gracias,
de la escucha, de la escucha.